it's time for the launching a television
journal of the important issues of the
art brought to you every Monday
Wednesday and Friday a presentation of
the lawn gene which nor wats company
well lon gene the world's most honored
wats wit nor distinguished companion to
the world up good evening this is frank
night co-editors for this edition of the
lawn gene chrome scope from the CBS News
staff Larry masseur ill chanel our
distinguished guest for this evening
Lord Strauss chairman of the fair
campaign practical as far back anyway
there was hope throughout the country
that the campaign's would be conducted
on a basis of play without personal
vilification and AB you detect a
committee was formed with target they
got pledges from the candidates I
understand that they would adhere to it
conduct a mrs. Strauss what has happened
to the pledges of fair play of honesty
decency I think we had a very percentage
sign those pledges considering time that
this happened and up till just recently
they did very well in living up in other
words you think of the helmet well if
there were any violations which side do
you think they were on it have been too
many because I wouldn't like any
violations at all at that kind of
mudslinging is not wise and I think come
election day that the voters book well
in other words you feel that it's
possible that these
but boomerang on a candidate well I do
indeed will faith in in the people in
this I think they like that kind of mud
and I think that they show it in their
vote well I think they have in the past
I believe that most people our standards
and this is a way of opportunity of
expressing pot they want they never
found and drew them up themselves yes I
can't put this code that our committee
has presented I think put a lot of
people have wanted and had in mind House
is there any way of policing these this
court know when the committee fact well
make this code available we decided that
we could but that we would leave it up
to the facts here when TV TV and to the
people of leasing and I think that that
in our is is the right way of doing it
mr. technology have been violations of
the code Jay and fair play happy now
would you pinpoint they blame at the
candidates or on the national leadership
well I don't think there's any one place
from I think that many people can
contribute to it and I think that it
often is a move of desperation that's
why there's been more of it the end of
the campaign I think the fact that some
of the things that have been said at the
very end when the really was ooh whether
they were so or not and I think that's
the thing that the voters will learn to
recognize if they haven't already in
will I that kind of attack is not a
justified what and they don't want it
and on Election Day they'll make it now
cause when you have a chance to evaluate
this campaign at another such campaign
their own fair practices what we hope to
is courage oh we're not discouraged a
bit and we are the editors will help us
evaluate we have a questionnaire we
about to the editors asking them what
they think about it and asking
suggestions how it might make more
effective other year mistress is it
possible for public themselves are
guilty of finding your pages by
exaggerated faience by indulging in
whatever for whispering campaigns which
is not due to the candidates or the
national leadership well I think
generally that the it was started by
somebody who would in a campaign there
is an initiating force and in any of
these campaigns of vilification personal
abuse even whispering campaign oh I
think there is the original force and
then I think that it is often taken up
by the people but I don't think very
often the people themselves have have
started it going and I think that the
fortunately the press and the people and
others contribute towards it but again I
think if we call it to their attention
and and show them how its to their own
disadvantage to have that kind of a
thing happen that a large majority of
the people will not do it I think it's
an awfully small number do the
name-calling and who like that kind of
thing and I think those of us who don't
have to get up and say we don't even say
that unser in no uncertain terms and
that's why what this fair campaign
practices committee is trying to do miss
Kraus would there be any would it be
practical to try and get some federal
legislation or perhaps a resolution
passed by the Congress endorsing this
code yes actually that was what was
originally thought of when the
subcommittee drew up thought it was
basically the same code that we are
using the Subcommittee on privileges and
elections but they didn't put it into
legislation and so we just a group of
citizens picked it up and said let's do
it by the force of public opinion to buy
mine died while I like it when public
opinion does something
and just speaks up and says we want the
best of our candidates and will demand
it of them stones now is the raising of
false and misleading issues one of the
dynamics of a party oh Ken politics be
conducted on purely intellectual lines I
think it can be done on intellectual if
you want or the facts of the situation
because i think this name-calling and
mudslinging and gets away from the real
issues and to my mind you can do a
wonderful educational job in part in
politics during a campaign and give the
people a real basis for making honest
decision the practical politician can
you appeal to the people through their
minds or through their emotions doesn't
it necessary to go to their emotions in
order to get them to vote yes but we
have good emotions as well as bad might
appeal to the good emotions when when
you're making the emotional appeal I
think it's a combination of intellectual
and emotional but let's have it on the
higher emotional appeal and not the
baser ones and what you think you can
make intellectual or mental issues into
emotional wounds by good is that good
politics I think we've got to make it
good politics and I think it is
increasingly good politics we just dated
before that that some of the candidates
for guilty of introducing issues that
could not be proved against their
opponents at the very tail end of the of
the campaign well isn't it good politics
if if they go into the election day
without being the other side being able
to disprove the charges that are made
against him no I hope it's got to be
this [ __ ] be shown that it's very bad
politics because I hope that the people
will recognize that it is name-calling
and that if those were real suspicions
they should have been brought out
earlier does your committee have any
plans for trying to evaluate a candidate
losing because of unfair practices well
we shall do it for our own satisfaction
to see the effectiveness of it but we as
a committee I'm not doing any evaluating
that we would make public as to whether
a candidate had lived up to it or not
that would put us on the spot be a
pretty good lesson though and
for some politician yes it would we hope
that the the people of selves the voters
on Election Day I got to do that type of
evaluation for us and that's much better
to give the majority that opportunity
instead of just a small committee let's
try speaking of evaluation you think
this should be limited on how far back
in opponent goes in using facts which
are not or issues which are not related
to the issues of the moment to smear an
opponent well I think that a time limit
no I think that pertinent facts should
be brought out but I don't think there's
a time limit on pigment ones but I think
that the the crux of the situation is
what is permanent pertinent well why
haven't if i may ask mrs. Strauss mr.
who I haven't women done more to clean
up politics after all that was one of
the reasons they gave for getting the
franchise when they first got women's
suffrage and since there are more women
than men why am they done more to to
wipe out by the force of their vote
these candidates who who violate the
pledges of fair play and decency that's
one of the reasons that was given for
giving women the vote actually I'll go
back to my own great-grandmother who was
one of the first people to work for the
vote and her basis she was a very strong
anti-slavery person was that women have
a contribution to make and they vote is
the crux of being able to make it and i
will say that i do think that we do have
somewhat higher moral standards that can
be applied but after all you know the
old so I've women were all angels the
men would have a very dull life and I
think that that the people that thought
that the whole political scene was going
to be made over just because women were
given the vote were being rather
unrealistic at that point do you feel
that our campaigns have cleaned up been
cleaned up in the last
years oh I do I think that they are on a
better plane but not as good as they
should be well mistress do you think
actually you've seen a few campaigns I
suppose you took election campaigns are
getting better or worse I think they're
getting better with the present campaign
that has taken place in the past few
days no but i'm saying is i think that
there is more honesty in campaigns now
than they used to be and I'm not pleased
until they're entirely cleaned up until
this code of fair campaign practices and
is entirely lived up to but I think this
is just another step that will help
improve them in other words you think
the force of public opinion as harnessed
by the women in the League of Voters in
this this committee of for fair play is
gaining more and more power in the end
the actual elections yes I think it is I
think that well we know that there's a
very considerable number of independent
voters and even within the party
independence and that's no subject in
itself how strict how much you should
vote is a party matter but i think this
degree of Independence means that people
are thinking on the their own and making
their own decisions and I think that
kind of decisions will mean that the
party will have to work with higher
standards just as I think the League of
Women Voters trains people to go into
their party and be more than yes men to
really make a contribution of up higher
standards to both political parties
thank you very much distress and so as a
pleasure to have a one of your high
principles can before a camera the
opinions expressed on the launch in
chroma scope for those of the speakers
the editorial board for this edition of
the launch in chrono scope was Larry
lesser and bill should L our
distinguished guest was an our Lord
struts chairman of the fair campaign
practices committee